as more migrants perish on the
Mediterranean trying to reach Europe
mostly from Libya at least 1800 have so
far this year MEP s have been debating a
new set of solutions from the European
Commission it includes field operations
against traffickers stronger common
asylum policy fresh ideas on legal
migration and binding quotas for EU
members to take in migrants promoting
the interest of all rather than focusing
on on single member states that is what
we have to do the individual should be
able to seek sanctuary in the first safe
country reached I do not believe that
quotas and forced relocation is
sustainable democratic or fair to the
individuals in question members from
countries in or on the Mediterranean
where migrant boots are landed welcomed
concerted action I particularly welcome
of course the reference to a
distribution mechanism which is a fine
and realization of the fact that this is
a European problem that requires a
European solution have been for long
calling for a naval operation with the
purpose of saving lives at the same time
to destroy the trafficking networks the
key next step a summative EU leaders in
June to agree the package including
quotas and military and intelligence
operations
you